and the royals are hoping they're better
and lefty
mike miner can keep them rather quiet
cesar hernandez will try to get things
going for cleveland
grounded and a diving play by alberto
in time so for a second straight night
against cleveland
the game begins with a very good
defensive play hands are alberto
man oh man the first hitter of the game
you've already done something great
if you do one good thing as a big
leaguer you've had a good game and right
there
saved in a double a possible run that
would have been a lead off double look
at him
he looked acrobatic right there phil
mates on will be
the uh indian starting pitcher and we'll
see how long
he's going to be the opener for tonight
his uh his very first start
ever now with two out we'll see if
narefield is inclined to
try to steal his ninth whit takes off
salvi takes high the throw is high
and hernandez did a great job of selling
wit
on receiving that throw and holding the
tag on him
and whit acknowledges that being a
second baseman himself so he'll be at
second base with two down got a nice
take off there's your stolen base that's
stolen base for whitt leads the league
so he's getting a nice head start on
monster comes back
the pits to him and he swings and misses
got him with a curve ball
so manton walked the lead off batter
then settled in
striking out a pair driving the royals
scoreless after one
three and two michael a taylor is on
deck
out over the plate and lined into left
field
hunter takes an aggressive turn he's
going to dig for second on lupelo
he is in there great slide
to the outside part of second base with
his left hand
and dozier has a one out hustling double
out over the plate and that's into left
center field
and dozier will run on lupe low again
luplos throw is cut off
and that might have been a break that
looked like a good throw that was online
so michael a taylor gives the royals a
one-nothing lead in the bottom of the
second
runners at second and third with one out
for salvador perez
very high right center field deep
ramirez and naylor are back and ramirez
did not make the play
bentendi was a little bit confused
and
everybody's confused right now and i
think third base coach vance wilson
from that angle couldn't tell if the
ball was caught
or dropped and the royals might argue
here
that the second base umpire david
rackley
called it a catch and that's that area
when
the ball blends in with that digital
scoreboard out there where it's very
difficult to see
if it's a catch or not a catch but
clearly that ball hit the dirt
but the runners all reacted as if
ramirez made the catch
so it blended in with that white out
there and it picked and naylor picked it
up
so quickly because who has the call
because the players that's all they have
well there was no call no but it's doing
anything so no wonder ben and tindy
he didn't know what to do whether to go
back and go all the way to third or what
okay now ben and tendy is going to be
awarded third base
the royals lead two nothing mike's
really been mitching
up his pitch as well in earlier games
but 52
fastballs in the first three innings of
this one
right center field and that's well hit
but it's slicing over toward right so
dozier isn't there to make the play
he clearly made that play that's right
one down
up into the twilight but salvi's on it
two outs and now mike miner has gotten
it out
against eight consecutive hitters fran
reyes
late last year had a five hit game here
at kauffman stadium
nicki lopez is there and the inning is
over and mike miner has gotten it out
from
nine straight indians hitters to the
plate step salvador perez
that is jolted into deep left center
field
and a salvi splash a grown man hit that
ball
that thing was shot out of a cannon man
that the trajectory of that ball it went
straight up in the air
and almost looked like a pop-up it just
carried
to seamer he knew it look at him load
those hips thing coming down
man wow what a beauty indians trying to
pull out of a three-nothing deficit they
have timid on one out in the sixth
now the one-two slow roller to third
scoop throw he beat it out old he called
him out
oh man it looked like jose was down the
line
and had gotten there they'll they'll
review this
that that looked like he was on the base
oh yeah he's on the base before he got
the ball
i don't even see where the umpire was in
that shot
oh yeah okay this has got to be
he looks safe three two one
done okay thank you oh that's good oh no
kidding
all right so that's an infield single
[Music]
slow chopper it got by the shortstop
lopez
the indians will score two and the tying
run goes to third
all the indians catch a break fred mill
reyes puts the ball in play
cesar hernandez jordan luplo both
scamper home and jose ramirez hustling
all the way to third base
and now a line drive base hit into left
field ties the game harold ramirez
wasting no time
it's 3-3 and all three charged to mike
miner
2-2 for harold ramirez shoots it fair
on the right field line coming around
third with the go ahead run
fred mill reyes will score harold
ramirez
has delivered with his second rbi hit of
the night
4-3 cleveland josh naylor one out of
three tonight
high fast ball hit it the other way
beautifully placed
coming around third harold's gonna try
to score the throw is nowhere near
anybody
it's backed up by the pitcher stalmont
well josh naylor
happy with the rbi single the indians
lead is now
five to three now the 2-2
there's a ball hit pretty well deep
right field dozier back on the track at
the wall that is gone
jake bowers with a booming blast here in
the eighth inning
on two out two run homer to make it a
four-run
uprising and the indians have exploded
in front
lead it now seven to three first and
third
one down seven to three cleveland carlos
santana the batter
there it is there you go fair ball how
about that
and a double play ends the ball game yes
let's go home so the indians win it
and they've taken the first two here in
kansas city to go to 15 and 13
on the year they've now won seven of
their last
nine